There are a couple of ways
of doing a 3D sensing
some of which we've already seen.
So Passive 3D sensing,
what do we mean by that?
That means you don't use
any active illumination,
that is you take the world as it's given
to you and you somehow sense that.
And maybe you exploit some known
geometry of the properties or
something about the scene.
So have we actually done something
that recovers geometry of the scene?
Well of course we have, right?
We've done stereo.
In fact, those of you who
are participating in the class for
credit have actually
matched stereo images.
So here's an example of
some some stereo rigs.
These are sort of amateur ones.
You know, I love this one, right?
Build the wooden blocks,
screw two cameras on, capture a picture.
Here's something a little more
sophisticated where you've got some high
end video cameras mounted on a rigid bar
that you can control the vergence angle.
But of course if any of you
gone to the movies lately,
you've probably paid
a lot of extra money,
in order to be able to entertain
your two eyes separately.
Or more precisely,
to see movies in 3D, stereo.
And here's the types of,
rigs that they use.
Some of you notice that's,
Spielberg on the right, in the middle
I think that's James Cameron.
He was behind, the making of Avatar.
Avatar was one of the first movies where
3D was fundamental to sort of
the experience of the movie.
And there have been a lot of 3D movies
before, and, obviously one since, but
in this non-film critic's view
of the universe, it, it is,
it was a seamless blending of sort
of what you would think of as normal
imagery, but
done in 3D along with computer graphics.
And so, the 3D experience wasn't
despite, wasn't just sort of
the experience of 3D was actually
crafted as part of the movie.
At least,
this is my part view of the universe.
And it's what it really made it,
and, and
the technology had come around
quite a bit with polarized light,
to really be able to give you
a compelling 3D experience.
There are other ways, also,
of getting depth from a natural image.
One, cool one, and we actually talked
a little bit about this when we were,
talking about focus pull, right?
Is that the way a lens works,
focal plane is actually in focus and
then some other, and the,
when things that are further away or
in front are not in focus, so you can
go from focus to depth, all right?
In fact, here's this cute little
animation of this scene, right,
where you can see that they're varying
the focal plane, and by varying
the focal plane you can figure out the
depth of different parts of the scene.
All right, so that's all passive.